au coeur d'une ville en pleine
construction les courts de tennis de la
possession résonne pour la finale du
mary pierce
indian ocean series la porte d'entrée du
circuit professionnel dames cette
compétition wta est une chance pour la
dizaine de réunionnaises en lice il y
avait un grand besoin et c'est le
tournoi idéale pour la ligue puisque il
est de petite catégorie c la catégorie c
la dotation 10000 on a pu cette lente
cette deuxième édition on a eu la chance
les petites ont eu la chance d'y
participer et elles étaient 6 quand même
réunionnaise un tableau c'est une
opportunité fabuleuse
elles ont même certaines passer le
premier tour dans les gradins
emmanuel a été éliminée par une autre et
nyonnaise mais ce tournoi est une étape
importante donc son parcours de haut
niveau en fait pour à vendre et que la
paroisse poignet pendant trois terrans
les effets car dans ce moment là j'étais
content de ma semaine utilité de ce
tournoi je trouve que c'est bien parce
que il n'y a pas beaucoup de filles
jeunes qui jouent au tennis à la réunion
donc du coup ça fait de la pub pour les
tennis et puis en plus mal et j'aime
bien venir voir les matchs des thoniers
donc zappé les ans et puis et puis avoir
des professionnels le sourire tranche
papaye pour ces filles qui n'ont pas
l'habitude d'un tel niveau de jeu
les professionnels de ce range des
professionnels en guinée parce que c'est
vraiment la première étape il viennent
que pour les points
c'est pour graver pour aller au dans les
tournois beaucoup plus haut il ya une
hiérarchie
il faut passer par les petits tournois
pour acquérir des points
et elle ne vienne surtout pas pour la
dotation qui est vraiment minime
en ce qui concerne la finale entre la
française et la néerlandaise malgré un
début de match plein de succès le mental
de la française n'a pas résisté
j'aurais aimé gagner c'est clair et net
après je me suis tu aurais je me suis un
peu posé trop de questions et je pense
que l'émotion vraiment ça a pris le
dessus
et j'aurais pas dû je pense que j'ai
trop pensé au score et j'aurais dû plus
penser à mes objectifs
voilà après j'espère juste ne pas
refaire la même erreur la semaine tu as
grandi là tu appris quelque chose
ouais je le savais déjà mais après au
tennis on sait les choses mais on le
fait pas on sait qu'on ne fait pas
forcément une finale sous le regard de
la meilleure réunionnaise du tournoi qui
a été éliminé en demi-finale par la
néerlandaise c'est sympa la vidéo niveau
c'est pas toujours évident c'est pas ce
qu'on croit toujours c'est à dire que
c'est beaucoup de sacrifices mais mais à
la fois c'est très plaisant parce que
voilà on voyage beaucoup on voit
beaucoup de chose est sûre ce côté à ccc
plaisant et puis tu vois là mais faut
qu'il y ait des sacrifices et les autres
voilà il ya plus que du décalage horaire
il ya des joueurs de voyage très longue
il ya des pays qui sont pas forcément
évident à gérer au niveau de la sécurité
et toutes ces choses là donc vous laisse
également vrai c'est assez je suis déjà
été touchée à d'accueillir un tournoi
envergure internationale sur la ville de
la possession un tournoi féminin
effectivement j'ai eu à coeur de suivre
pauline payet notre réunionnais 20 hier
bon elle s'est inclinée face à une
chienne
formidable qui a confirmé effectivement
son niveau de jeu aujourd'hui en
remportant la finale on est fiers et le
département effectivement depuis de
nombreuses années a eu à coeur
d'accompagner à travers différents
dispositifs comme les différents
subventions le tennis aujourd'hui et
jouer partout par dans tous les
quartiers le foot a été accessible en
amont mais aujourd'hui le tennis bientôt
l'équitation qui permet de découvrir des
pépites est effectivement arrivé à
représenter la réunion a au plus haut
niveau
on a tous le droit d'y croire
cette organisation porté par mary pierce
semble être une opportunité pour cette
discipline qui rêve de voir un jour une
réunionnaise en haut de la fiche